what if the bad habit can be tough so
why bother
here are the surprising health benefits
of the worst habits some people may
think they need to drink less coffee but
before they make any rash decisions they
should know that moderate coffee
consumption has been linked to a
decreased risk for type 2 diabetes and
Alzheimer's on top of that heavy coffee
consumption has been shown to lower the
risk of certain cancers which cancers
doesn't matter they're pretty much all
bad
the Bible says gossiping will incur
God's wrath but a Brown University study
has found that it might be good for you
too
their research has shown that just 20
minutes of discussing other people's
business can provide hours of stress
relief so the next time you feel like
you might need a massage just call up
some friends and talk it's basically the
same thing and it's cheaper biting your
nails can be good for you
but you're not going to like the reason
why when you bite your nails you are
eating just the tiniest amount of bugs
that's the bad news the good news is
that you're eating such a tiny amount of
bugs you are actually training your
immune system to be more effective the
same principle applies to eating your
own boogers now the only reason to stop
is so you're not a social outcast all
right you guys are getting the hang of
this let's go speed round just knocks
them out real quick chocolate two ounces
of chocolate per day can cut your LDL
cholesterol by up to 14 percent
improving blood flow almost 50% boom
fidgeting fidgeting shown to have faster
metabolisms and better circulation boom
heroin despite its reputation actually
has several health benefits I am just
kidding there are no positives to doing
heroin but procrastination can be good
for you German researchers have found
that when you take a break from work
your body boost the production of the
compounds that fight aches and pains and
this break can take the form of playing
with a pet maybe reading a book really
much anything but heroin is gonna work
so go ahead procrastinate watch another
YouTube video and maybe eat some
chocolate